I'm Daniel Ehrenberg and I work in TC39 and I came here to tell you about bigint
Let's talk about numbers.
Math.pow(2, 53) is a function that can take
a number to a particular power.
X will be to the 53rd power.
You can write two to **53.
What does that equal?
Starting with a nine and ending with a two.
What do you get if you add one to that?
Two to the 53 plus one.
The same number back.
A huge number, nine end, a two before what
is going on?
In this talk, I will tell you about why numbers
do this, how we can fix this using BigInt,
and how TC39 has been developing BigInt in
partnership with the JavaScript community,
and how you can get involved to shape the
next version of JavaScript.
I really want your help in all of this.
We can't do it without you.
So, first about numbers: numbers in JavaScript
are 64-bit floats, floating point, binary,
numbers.
So that is basically like scientific notation.
Remember, from grade school, 30,000, you could
represent as 3 times ten to the five?
Here, the component would be 5.
The sine is positive 1 and the fraction is
3.
I triple e - it's base two instead of base
ten.
We have the sign that is one bit, and the
component which is 11 bit, and the fraction,
52 bits.
So, our friend 2 to the 53rd power looks like
this when you put it in a floating point.
Sine is zero to represent positive 1.
Component is that number starting with a 1,
and the fraction is all zeros.
It has an implicit 1-point before the zeroes.
The next biggest number is that ending with
a four.
If you look at the last digit, the last digit
of this number ending a 2 is 0, and the one
being 1 is 1.
There are actually no numbers in between.
When I say "number", I mean the binary floating
point numbers.
Ultimately, if we are representing something
in 64 bits, there is only 2 to the 64 different
bit pattern, so we can't represent every single
actual number that exists in the world, or
every single integer.
At some point, we have to round or go up to
infinity or have an error.
This seems like a random case.
This never comes up in practice.
It turns out it president in Twitter's API,
there's an ID field, tweets represented by
good afternoon, objects, and the idea that
you get over the network looks like this,
this big number ending in 888.
When you parse that in JavaScript, it gets
converted to a number.
So, the 8, 888 rounds to 900.
For this reason, Twitter includes a secondary
field, ID string, which is a string of the
number, and that doesn't round, but people
run into this as a problem all the tile.
Like it's kind of easier to use the ID rather
than the ID stream, and it's hard for Twitter
to remove it because of compatibility.
Sometimes, the numbers don't overflow, like
in that second line in this bug, but other
times, they do, and you just are referring
to the wrong object.
Another case this comes up is inode numbers.
Each file is generally associated with a number,
a pointer to the file.
Node.js includes an API called stat to read
the inode numbers on a file.
On Linux, inode numbers are often kind of
low, but on Windows, they can be high and
run into the same kind of rounding issue.
So this L stat sync, there's a reproducible
test case where you can create a couple of
files in that folder which have inode numbers
which one of them ending in 27 but then it
rounds up to
the same 28.
If you try to parse those numbers back to
the system again, it is not going to work.
It is the wrong number.
To get around these kinds of problems, there
are libraries created which gives you an object
API for this where you can instantiate a new
big num and call methods on it to add or things
like that.
There are some limitations here, because it's
not integrated into the system, so, if you
have something else in the standard library,
or in the web platform or node, it's not obvious
how to integrate with this.
It's not optimisable so the JavaScript engine
can't use knowledge of mathematics to make
it faster.
It is an extra thing to download and integrate
which is difficult in some projects.
So, what if we had this in JavaScript itself?
Going back to the original example, where
we add one and we get the same number back
again, what if we could indicate that we want
to refer just to integers using a sufficient
if I can like n?
2n to the 53n would be the same number starting
with a 9 and ending with a 2, but when you
add 1 into it, you get 3 at the end.
N here, the 2 goes to 3.
N here stands for BigInt.
Is this JavaScript?
It is.
Soon.
BigInt is at stage 3 in TC39, and we are adding
it to the JavaScript programming language.
It is shipping in Chrome now as of a few days
ago, shipping in Chrome 57, and node Master
is, BigInt is being supported.
BigInt is is being being supported in Firefox
and South Africa are an as well and on the
road map for Edge.
What is TC39 do my JavaScript in ES6 gave
you nice features like destructuring.
If you had two variables, X and Y, you can
swap them by putting in an array on the left-hand
side and just swapping them.
And so this and other things like asynch await
were added by TC39.
TC39 is a standards committee that is part
of Ecma.
Ecma is this standards body based in Geneva,
sort of administrative support, but then we
in the committee are JavaScript developers,
implementers, people who are making JavaScript
work in web browsers, and node, and Babel.
Framework authors like Angular, ember, and
React, and we all get together to produce
this document: the Ecma Script Language Specification.
If you were to print this out, it would be
more than 1,200 pages.
I recommend just looking at the website.
It has these nice searching features.
We developed this document on GitHub.
It's an open-scores project like any other
with issues and pull requests, and we also
develop it at meetings, so here, there's a
part of an agenda for the meetings.
We always seem to run over a little bit on
the agenda, but we meet every two twos more
three days, and we talk about the activity
on GitHub, and we also talk about new proposals
to be extending the language.
These proposals move through stages, so, if
it is a big proposal like BigInt, we don't
just have a pull request against the main
spec and start with that, we instead make
a separate proposal.
It goes through these stages.
You might have heard of stage 1 is just a
general idea, we're justifying a problem space
within the committee.
Stage 2 means that we have an agreed-on first
draft that TC39 has decided we are going to
do something here, and it's going to look
more or less like this.
By stage 3, all the details are worked out,
and we have a complete first specification,
and it's ready to go off to implementers.
And by stage 4, we have multiple implementations,
and lots of feedback from real usage, so we're
ready to make it part of the actual JavaScript
standard.
So how did BigInt and through this process?
Actually, BigInt s or n64 has been in environment
for longer than the stage process, longer
than Chrome and Node.
Back in 1999, after JavaScript was created,
long and you long types were proposed, holding
unsigned 64-bit integers.
This 3, that update was expansions to the
library, like regular expressions.
ES4 was this huge project that was thinking
of adding these types but it got so complicated
that it just had to be abandoned be, and,
in ES5 to recover and heal from that process,
the language changes were really minimal,
and included things like cleaning up the object
model, and eval, and a view other library
editions - a few other library editions.
E6 made a whole bunch of changes, such as
this destructuring assignment that I mentioned.
As part of ES6, the committee was talking
about adding value types, which would have
been user-de fined data types, so user-defined
primitives.
You can already define your own objects but
you can't define your own thing as a JavaScript
programmer.
We're still talking about doing value types,
but they weren't added in ES6 but deferred
until later.
Long history of not jet doing larger integers,
but then recently, in November 2016, Brendan
Eich proposed again to the committee that
we do in 64, rather than coupling it to the
whole value-type package, in 64, and unsigned
in 64 was proposed as a standalone proposal,
to add this one new primitive type.
We wanted to do it rather than BigInt rather
than 64.
I will talk more about the reasons in a bit.
Then, by the July, we got to see ... process.
Now shipping in 67.
Let's go over how this happens in more detail.
For stage one, what you need is to have a
description of the problem, and so, what we
did in TC39 is create this ... [sound distorted].
... inviting various members participate to
give opinions about various different semantic
points.
So, a couple of big discussions that we went
through were big - I mentioned in the history
that much of the time we've been discussing
adding 64-bit integers to the language rather
than adding other tree size integers.
Some of the reasons for that were some people
felt like it would be a more minimal addition,
so, if you have a 64-bit integer, it would
overflow or throw an exception when you get
out of bounds.
That could work.
For a lot of the applications, it works.
The whole point of the proposal is to avoid
the overflow.
Sometimes, 64 bits is enough.
People thought this would be maybe easier
to convince browsers to implement, or it might
execute faster, but, when we talked more with
the browsers, actually benefit from the V8
team, sort of led this effort to re consider
arbitrary sized integers.
This way, you never have to worry about overflow,
and it actually turns out that the way that
modern JavaScript engines work, they have
machinery for doing this sort of optimisation
for working with numbers in particular ranges,
to convert them to integers.
And, at the same time, n64 wouldn't be that
fast without all sorts of optimisations, because
it has to be allocated in the heap, you have
to do all sorts of type-checking, and to get
it to the point where it's allocated in registers
or on the stack, there is already a lot of
magic going on.
When that same magic is apply, it would work
for BigInt.
We decided to bite the bullet, solve the whole
problem better go and go with BigInt rather
than n64.
The other big semantic point we discussed
is what to do with mixed types.
So, in a language like Python, you can just
add a - you can just add a large integer and
a float, and you get a float back, and what
we decided for JavaScript is we don't want
to do that.
What we're doing instead, I mean, the whole
point of BigInt is to be this new data type
that provides this mathematical accuracy.
You don't have to think about all the complexity
of IEE74.
You can just think about integers, but what
integer would you get when you add a very
large integer, 2 to the 53 plus 1.5?
The answer isn't actually contained in this
set of integers or in the set of representable
float-point values.
What we decided is, rather than come up with
the wrong answer, when the whole point of
the feature is to come to the right answer,
we would throw a type error in this case.
We would say we're not going to come to an
answer.
Actually, you can't mix BigInts and numbers
in general in mathematical operations.
This leads to a best practice that I recommend.
BigInt are good when you have a value that
ranges that might be larger than what can
be represented in numbers, but if numbers
are working for you, stick with them.
Numbers still worked just fine for small integers,
and in general, because we have to make make
this decision up front, it is because of that.
That issue I just described, you know, numbers
in use for what they're in use for right now,
still works very well.
So to get to stage 2 from there, the committee
wrote this draft specification document, and
this is like the main document for the whole
specification except that it is only the segment
that relates to this new feature, so it includes
some insertions, deletions, and some new sections,
but you can ultimately read it in the same
HTML file.
That's generated from this specification form
- format, in let's you use a combination of
markdown and grammar syntax easily to generate
these specification drafts.
My co-work er Robyn Templeton implemented
BigInt in SpiderMonkey, which is currently
starting to land.
So, even though stage 3 is when something
is really, really ready for implementation,
and really stable, it's never too early to
get started prototyping, and this process
leads to - helps the development of the feature.
To get to stage 3, we needed sign-off on this
specification.
In particular, a couple of committee members,
or more than a couple of committee members,
volunteer to read the whole specification
in a lot of detail, as well as the editors,
and see whether it's ready this.
Leads to a lot of typos being fixed and cases
being looked at closely, and, once we got
to this level of stability where the committee
has signed off and the committee is really
saying, "Yes, we want to to this feature,"
stage 2 is, "We want to do this feature,"
and stage 3 is, "We want to do it this way,
and we need implementation feedback."
This level of stability led the V8 team to
implement BigInt.
Following that, the - so, you know, thank
you Jacob for great work leading the BigInt
implementation, and Kyle Lima worked on BigInt
in KLC which is in progress.
Even once we got to a stage 3, even once we
said that we have this level of stability,
there were still some Edge cases that people
came across, which, because the feature hasn't
shipped to the web yet, we were opening to
revisiting.
So there were tons of different edge cases
like this that we spent committee time on
before getting to stage 3, and, even after
stage 3, we looked at this one.
You know double equals and less than, in JavaScript,
you can use them to compare a number and a
string, and, when you do that, it converts
the string to a number, and it compares them
as numeric values.
So, you know, this is part of JavaScript being
maybe weekly typed, and having all these casts
everywhere, and so, to make sure that BigInt
is consistent with - to make sure that BigInt
is consistent with numbers.
We did that same behaviour in BigInt.
In this second case, accidentally we were
converting BigInt to a number, and it wouldn't
compare as less than when it is actually the
same value, because that number would be rounding
down.
To get to stage 4, what we are going to need
is full tests, there's a performance test
suite that verifies that implementations are
working right, so we have those conformance
tests.
A full request, there's still more refactor
to go do for that, and two implementations
where we have one full implementation, but
the next two are still in progress.
So maybe we will get this by ES2019, or ES2020
- I hope so.
So, to let you know how to get involved, there's
just a lot of different ways to get involved
here.
Feedback on GitHub issues is really great.
I love to hear about whether feature proposal
works for you.
If there are pieces missing or if a case should
be handled differently, and this was really
useful for working through tons of issues
with BigInt.
Test 262 tests, there's a project to implement
tests for the JavaScript language itself.
And it's an open-source project that's happy
to have new contributions.
What we find is that, when something is missing
from the test suite, actually, different browsers
or different JavaScript implementations have
different behaviour, because different people
end up reading the same specification differently
by accident, and so it's really important
to have a full test suite.
There are other parts.
Other have tests like web platform tests,
and so, for example, here's a pull request
to add tests that check that adding a number
in a BigInt throws a type error.
For the BigInt project, it helps make implementations
right the first time and say correct.
Sometimes, a joke was made to me, sometimes,
implementations make so many optimisations
that they optimise away the specification
itself.
This will prevent that.
As you're maintaining the project, you have
these complete correctness tests.
But, it went even further than that, because
the people working on these tests took a really
close look at all the Edge cases, and helped
work through a lot of design decisions.
More than six test engineers collaborated,
especially from Boku and Egalia.
We are happy to have help, documentation and
education.
With this readme file, a number of people
contributed.
It's important to understand the different
mental models that JavaScript programmers
have.
People aren't programming thinking through
the entire specification, and different people
have different mental models, so this is especially
useful.
We tried to compare a bunch of different ways
of thinking through code when designing language
features.
For example, in the BigInt design process,
Ashley Williams pointed out that, when learning
programming, a lot of programmers have an
intuition that variables should have particular
types.
So, this made us feel not quite as bad about
not permitting mixed operations between BigInt
and number because this is an intuitive thing
for people to learn, that a value has a particular
type.
It's also welcome to implement things, so
you can contribute to lots of implementations
in JavaScript, so, through implementations,
it's not just about getting JavaScript to
developers, all these three implementations
of BigInt that are in progress have contributed
to the design of the feature.
It's also possible, if you're not able to
do this development yourself, companies like
Bloomberg and Google sponsor work to push
these things forward, and of course, in these
meetings, we are open to new members, so,
let me know if you want to get involved as
a TC39 delegate.
It's an organisational membership.
Something like your employer would join, or
there are also non-profit memberships.
So, as a takeaway, please, if you're interested
in building the future of JavaScript, get
involved in TC39.
You can go to our website, and you know, now
you have BigInts, and cruise them for iterators
which may be big, and use numbers for numbers
that are smaller.
So, I'm Little Dan, and thank you!
[Applause].